germany's foreign ministry is calling
for a transparent probe into abuse
claims after more evidence emerged of
china's brutal crackdown on its
predominantly muslim uighur minority a
cache of documents dubbed the xinjiang
police files was leaked to international
media including photographs inside
xinjiang's mass incarceration facilities
it's a rare look behind the walls of a
so-called re-education camp in the
northwestern chinese province the photos
show police using physical force against
prisoners in handcuffs and chains the
leak was published by a consortium of
investigative journalists including from
the bbc and to germany's der spiegel and
ard the publication coincides with the
arrival in china of the u.n human rights
commissioner michelle bachelet
we're now joined by frederick obama from
the german media outlet der spiegel he
is one of the about 30 investigative
journalists behind this story so very
good to have you with us
uh first of all after years of denial by
the chinese government your research
gives hundreds of thousands of abused
uighurs a face
please help us to understand the meaning
of it by sharing the story that stood
out most for you
i think
the most important thing about the
xinjiang police files is that we now see
faces attached to this crime against
humanity we see thousands of people
detained
in camps in northwestern china
we see 15 year old children being
detained up to
all the elderly uh women like 73 year
old woman being detained there and first
of all first and foremost we see the
argument of the chinese government
counted the argumentation so far was
that this is vocational schools that
people are there on their own will they
they could leave whenever they want but
in the documents that were leaked to us
we see now a shoot to kill policy we see
that the uyghurs in those camps were
held there by force
now the data set consists of uh more
than 5000 photos many of them showing
sensitive and security related footage
do we know who they take them and why
no we don't know who exactly um
uh took those photos we have hints that
it was people working in those camps
taking them
like for example mugshots of the people
detained there and then like making
photos of their exercises of them
treating
the detailed individuals
and then the data
was obtained by a source who leaked it
to a german
scientist called adrian sense
so far we have to
think that
the source could be a hacker
obviously the data comes from within the
chinese
government and authority operators and
we were able to independently verify uh
the documents and the photos
i mean it is a strange thought to think
that the handling of the people would be
documented in in such a way
do we know or how could you assess that
these pictures are actually real and not
fake
well first and foremost we
did hire independent experts who looked
and checked the authenticity of the
photos if they were manipulated in any
way
um then we at a second step we did
geolocate those many of those photos for
example whenever you could see something
uh in the uh pictures that was outside
of the camps for example walls towers
um and stuff like that and we were we
were able to geolocate them
with the help of satellite images we
also were able to
find uh information in the metadata of
the photos that showed us that they were
taken within um camps that could be seen
from space
via satellites
and then we also were able um to speak
with us living outside china
and who could um
let their relatives
that we have seen on those photos and
and on the list of uh detained
individuals that they were
disappeared basically several months or
even years ago okay
well thank you so much frederic
obermeyer from german media outlet der
spiegel one of the about 30
investigative journalists behind this
story thank you so much for sharing it
with us
thanks for having me